ladies and gentlemen die model manager
star gefallen
wiesbaden danke meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren reaction auch in germany next
topmodel selbstverständlich hat sich der
bau auch heute wieder in schale geworfen
diesmal mit einem apple ist das guthaben
und jule geld eure fashion-ikone lucius
von und zu lotsen bord hat sich hier
selbstverständlich wieder in schale
geworfen
da ich vor einigen tagen ja bereits
schon auf james ex topmodel die
kandidatinnen 2009/10 reagiert habe
elisa alter 24 berufen
ja davon wahnsinns kandidaten dabei in
meiner vision haben wir allerdings nur
zehn kandidatinnen geschafft da ich mich
mit jeder kandidatin zu sehr auseinander
gesetzt habe von daher sind noch 25
kandidaten auf der strecke geblieben die
ich mir noch nicht angeschaut habe und
das machen wir heute
ich habe meine brille vergessen so jetzt
kann ich die models aussehen isabel ist
die erste kandidatin die wir uns heute
anschauen werden das hier sind die
bilder von der lieben isabel sie ist 19
jahre alt ihr beruf ist
fremdsprachenkorrespondentin nicht mal
das konnte ich richtig aussprechen wenn
ich nicht will dass man mich mag dann
verhalte ich mich auch so dass man mich
nicht mag
ich würde mir auch unglaublich werden
das video hier von der isabella
anschauen aber das liegt irgendwie nicht
mehr bei mir ich hoffe ich wurde nicht
blockiert irgendwie für diese website
das hier sind die bilder von der isabell
mit diesem schoko schnitzel ist es
einfach
eins zu eins das gleiche bild das eine
hat 193 likes und das andere 111 muss
man nicht verstehen wo sie mich
verstehen
da kann ich auch einfach leiten kann
aber ich kann den weg nicht wieder
wegnehmen das super isabelles ein ganz
normales mädchen und dementsprechend
auch eine ganz normale kandidaten
nämlich sehen sie jetzt nicht unbedingt
als gewinnerin aber sie sind liebe
glaube ich lese kandidatin ist cecilia
ein sehr interessanter name sie ist 18
jahre alt erste sie ist beim
bundesfreiwilligendienst digger respekt
alter hat auf jeden fall mehr likes als
isabelle das hier sind die bilder von
der cäcilia es so aus jetzt wird sie
gerade seine küche hergeben auch liegt
ja noch pizza cäcilia hat als satz
hingeschrieben mir haben viele gesagt
ich sehe aus wie candle
m
die waren wohl blind
ist das mittelhessische hier in
frischhaltefolie eingewickelt die
cäcilia sieht jetzt nicht schlecht aus
aber ich finde jetzt nicht dass sie
aussieht wie kendall jenner
ich zeige euch mal kendall jenner also
das sind mal beide nebeneinander
das ist in meinen augen so wie wenn ein
glas tomatensaft neben dem mond stellst
alicia alicia ist 18 jahre alt sie ist
von beruf studentin und ihr satz ist
meine freunde nennen mich mutter teresa
als ein blog er sie heiß halten wir
haben ein paar so bilder vor somme
sterben hier wird einfach bekommen und
andere haben so bumerangs heißt es die
mit bumerang sind cooler und kommen er
weiter lena ist die nächste m
ein bisschen komplett ausrasten lena ist
17 sie ist angehende friseurin und sie
wurde ausgelacht weil sie sich bei gntm
was ich meine sie hat es geschafft in
die sendung zu kommen und hat den leuten
die sie ausgesandt haben wahrscheinlich
jetzt ordentliche revanche verpasst sie
hat hier unten auch diese bilder vor dem
sternenhimmel
ich finde ich finde die hat was die lena
die hat was
ja was die hat weiß ich nicht aber
irgendwas hat die idee sieht sie aus wie
jesse von team rocket also der jazz hier
rechne ich mir auf jeden fall hohe
chancen aus weiter zu kommen wenn ich da
jetzt auch nicht dass sie so eine ist
die rom holt wenn man irgendwie haare
abschneidet oder färbt aber die bringen
dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie anders zum
heulen marlene das hier ist die marlene
sie ist 19 ein ganz normales mädchen
studiert auch und ihr satzes ich kann
lautes atmen und schmerzen nicht hören
mag jetzt sehen uns auch gern mehr die
julia ist die nächste kandidatin von
germany's next topmodel 2009 10 das hier
ist die julia die siegchance und wer sie
gut bestückt die ist 23 sie ist von
beruf krankenpflegerin und sie arbeitet
in einer psychiatrie oder als
krankenpflegerinnen der psychiatrie
arbeit und nebenbei bei germany's next
topmodel die nähere auswahl kommen da
ziehe ich hier wirklich meine brille und
meinen schalen nicht aber die brille
sich ab vor deiner leistung weiter
geht's mit der lieben olivia von ihr
schauen wir uns auch die sachen an hier
das ist die olive die erinnert mich sehr
sehr krass an serena hat er ja das
gibt's von milch also 16 jahre ist schon
krass ist die jüngste die ich bisher
hier gesehen habe man sieht auch dass
sie ein sehr junges gesicht hat alter
oder sie dort ist die schwester von den
von gossip girl allerdings denke ich
dass die olivia wirklich auch sehr weit
kommen wird die sache ist nur die muss
dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann
rausfliegen weise zurück zur schule muss
das jetzt die liebe ann-kathrin sie 20
jahre alt sie ist von beruf eine
bürokauffrau und ihr ex-freund hat ihr
vorgeschrieben wie viele täler sie essen
schlafen
die ann kathrin hat hier unten auch kein
bumerang sondern
er hat schon ein hübsches gesicht ich
würde mir halt nie ein tattoo stechen
lassen und erst recht nicht in bunten
farben es geht ja darum wie ich die
models einschätze und ich denke dass die
weit kommt aber tattoos sind halt
einfach überhaupt nicht mein ding und
ich glaube dass auch tattoos im
model-business eine sache sind also ich
denke dass das ihr wirklich noch zum
verhängnis werden könnte ich hoffe es
nicht weil sie echt ein süßes mädchen
ist beziehungsweise 2 andrea okay 20
mädchen würde ich sagen allerdings
machen wir direkt weiter mit der
nächsten kandidaten und zwar maria
mutter maria hier die komplett in gold
gekleidet ist es einfach eins zu eins
foto noch einmal mit lachen und einmal
ohne lachen maria ist 19 jahre alte sie
ist azubi und viele sagen ich wäre
arrogant und eingebildet ja sie hat was
sie weiß sich zu präsentieren aber man
man sie tatsächlich sofern man das an
einem bildschirm beurteilen kann dass
sie leicht eingebildet wirkt ich glaube
sie wird so ein bisschen drama queen
also sie wird so viel beef haben mit
einigen leuten vor allem wenn sie
wirklich selbst das ist wieder 11 das
gleiche foto glaube sie wird
weiterkommen aber nicht ins finale wenn
juni dabei stehen würde dann die hat das
direkt gewonnen simone ist hier die
nächste dass sie sind die bilder von der
simone m die wirkte auf den bildern sehr
erwachsen obwohl sie erst 21 ist sie ist
ehemalige leistungssportlerin und ich
habe meine beine kaputt trainiert geil
da würde ich dich eigentlich direkt
rausschmeißen aus der staffel eine sind
doch so mit das wichtigste als mode und
wenn du da schmerzen hast wenn du
irgendwie was machst oder so dann ist es
vielleicht nicht so gut in das business
einzusteigen haben hier auch wieder
frischhaltefolie shooting nächste
kandidatin ist eine person die meinen
namen geklaut hatte lucia heißt sie ist
19 jahre alt von beruf studentin mein
freund zeigt gerne seine muskeln auf
instagram wahnsinn
also was dafür setze immer über die
leute stehen nie lucia hat tatsächlich
gar keinen
foto je nach ich glaube dass nicht nur
gutes zeichen liebe janka ist die
nächste kandidaten
sie steht hier auf jeden fall schon wie
ein topmodel zeigt ihre kurven hier
steht sie eher wie 39 war schon bei
austria's next topmodel
die bank hat der dann auf jeden fall
wieder bilder vor dieser mail wandte und
hier auch wieder bumerang sichert beides
sogar deren bianca ich glaube du hast
gute chance weiterzukommen das hier ist
die liebe nach oben
sie hat auf jeden fall gute kurven dafür
dass sie erst 16 ist und sie hat mit der
schule aufgehört weil ja davon halten
soll ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt ich
hoffe dass sie weit kommt weil sie sehr
viel ausstrahlung mitbringt bekommt auf
jeden fall auch ein like von mir
allerdings machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten kandidatin von germany's next
topmodel 2009 10 rund zwar logisch so
sieht sie aus
sie wirkt hier leicht wie sonne tänzerin
hat sollen wir gegen so einen gewissen
flair dadurch dass sie auch bauchfrei
ist sie ist 24 jahre alt von beruf
studentinnen und wenn ich eine glatze
bekomme steige ich aus ich weiß auf
jeden fall wegen dieser staffel eine
glatze geschnitten wird villiger ist die
nächste kandidaten
sie sieht so aus sie ist 22 jahre alt
angehende studentin und ihr look ist
offensiv und sie entdeckte sicht oft in
lady gaga
ja luna ist die nächste kandidatin eine
eigene farm ist mein großer traum will
farmerin werden geht zu germany's next
topmodel lara ist die nächste kandidatin
den namen habe ich so noch nie gehört
egal
gute figur macht ich finde das immer so
affig wenn leute sagen ich bin von beruf
influenza man jede person ist ein
influenza also sie ist 19 jahre alt ist
von beruf info hinteren und ihr satz es
gibt fanpages von meinem freund und mir
auf interview ziemlich abstoßend
anastasia ist die nächste kandidaten
sie hat auch in sehr guten körper aber
ich glaube sie ist relativ klein so wie
das hier aus sieht nichts gegen kleine
menschen habe ich das als ein model ist
es schon nachteil bis 21 jahre alt von
beruf studentinnen und gutes aussehen
ist in unserer welt wichtig die wird
sich viele feinde machen das hier sind
die bilder von der leoni kann sich auf
jeden fall auch gut präsentieren sie ist
18 jahre erst alt ist von beruf
hotelkauffrau und wenn ich auf eine
party kommen wird die stimmung besser
[Musik]
die nächste kandidatin ist die liebe
jasmin sie ist 18 jahre alt von beruf
kellnerin und sie möchte heidi einen
kaktus schenken
ich weiß nicht ob du wurst aber du bist
bei germany's next topmodel nicht
germany's next gärtnerin tatjana ist
unsere vierte letzte kandidatin für
heute
sie ist noch nie in ihrem leben gereist
also die tatjana die ganze zeit nur auf
einer stelle gelebt sorry aber reisen
ist ja auch schon zum kühlschrank läufst
hathaway ist die vorletzte kandidatin
auf die wir heute reagieren werden so
wie sie aussieht auf jeden fall eine
sehr sehr sehr sehr gute figur das muss
man direkt sagen sie ist 19 jahre alt
von beruf in flins lerin geil
glückwunsch und sie ist auch model und
hier steht als satz mehr als nur die
freundin von felix götze
wer ist fix kürze
es ist irgendwie das kind von mario
götze ich glaube schon dass sie weit
kommen wird weil man sieht hier sie hat
sehr deutliche ähnlichkeit mit dieser
look green
[Musik]
also eine ziemlich natürliche person
glaube ich dass sie weit kommen wir die
frage ist nur wenn man da schon hin
schreibt hey ich bin model in kürzeren
und mein freund ist irgendwie dem mann
wohl kennen sollte da bin ich ja mal
gespannt wie es einerseits bei den
anderen kandidatinnen und andererseits
auch bei den zuschauern ankommen wird
aber gut wir machen weiter mit der
letzten kandidatinnen meine lieben
freunde zu jana das ist dieser jana 20
jahre alt studentin und ihre verlobung
ist schon in planung mit 20 alter
respekt schätze ich jetzt keine großen
chancen aber ich denke bei jeder
kandidat ist es ja so aus irgendeinem
grund ist sie ja weiter gekommen aus
irgendeinem grund ist die von allen
leuten sich beworben hat jetzt schon in
den top 30 40 50 keine ahnung wie viel
dazu beginnen sind also ich muss
wirklich jeder kandidatin direkt sagen
hey das geht hier nicht gegen euch
persönlich und auch wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie sagen du kommst afe weiter und
du dich ich glaube du kommst nicht
weiter ich habe keine ahnung wie man
natürlich bin ich fashion icon model
manager und starfotograf aber ich möchte
einmal dass ihr versteht also einerseits
einige kandidatinnen die dass sie ja
wahrscheinlich sehen werden und der
schal ist halt echt von gucci rede
versteht dass das ganze hier nur spaß
ist und wie switches
[Musik]